النسبه ترتفع طبعا نسبه الفارس
98.88
اردوغان متقدم بنسبه
52.08 مقابل كلتش دار اوغلو الذي تحصل حتى
الان على نسبه
47.92% ونحن نتابع على الشاشه فرحه انصار
اردوغان خاصه بعد كلمته التي تحدث فيها عن
شعارات هاتف معهم وكذلك تحدث عن التحديات
المستقبليه ادعوك لتكمل فكرتك سيد خشيد
تفضل
يعني كنت اريد قوله ان الاكراد في تركيا
بشكل عام صوته للديمقراطيه صوتوه للتغيير
في تركيا صوتوا من اجل بناء حراك سياسي
جديد يمكن من خلال هذا الحوار اطلاق عمليه
سياسيه تغير من وجه تركيا بعد ان اتسممت
بالتحول الى حكم حزب الواحد وبعد ان تم
اقصاء كل الملاحظين او محاوله ممارسه كل
الاجراءات لمناهضتهم ولكن دعيني ايضا ان
اشير ان هناك قسم ايضا من الاكراد صوتوا
للرئيس اردوغان وهؤلاء معظمهم من التيار
الاسلامي ولا سيما حزب هدى بار وكذلك من
بعض العشائر الذين لهم ارتباط بحكومه حزب
العداله والتنميه الخلاصه التي يمكن
القولها ذكريات استطاعوا ان يسلطوا لصالح
هويه قوميه هذا اولا ومن ثم من اجل
التغيير الديمقراطيه في تركيا ولكن واضح
ان الرئيس اردوغان وضع كل الامكانات
الدوله تحت تصرف حملته الانتخابيه وبهذه
الامكانات لم امام مرشح المعارضه الذي لم
يفتقر الى مثل هذه الامكانيات وكانت
النتيجه ان اعتقادي طبيعيه في صلب معطيات
الواقع التركي ولا سيما توجه تركي الى
التصويت على الهويه القوميه التركيه والتي
اصبحت تشكل خطرا انا باعتقادي حتى على
الداخل التركي فما بالك بالخا طيب بالعوده
كذلك
كلمه اردوغان والتي تحدث فيها في الواقع
وكان ملفت حديثه وهنا سؤال حضرتك سيد
بركات كان ملفت حديث اردوغان عن
الانتخابات المحليه هو قال العين على 24
وكانه لم يخسر الكثير من الوقت
العداله والتنميه فازوا بالانتخابات
البرلمانيه بمعنى انهم تحصلوا على النسبه
الاعلى اردوغان تحول مباشره الى
الانتخابات الرئاسيه الجوله الاولى كانت
لصالحه ولكن النسب فرضت جوله ثانيه هذه
الجوله الثانيه متقدم فيها وفجاه في اسط
نبول يختار في خطابه ان يتكلم عن
الانتخابات المحليه هل الطريق بات مفتوح
تماما امام العداله والتنميه لهذه
الانتخابات او ان الحسابات قد تختلف
انا بتقدير الحسابات ستختلف طبعا وهناك
طبعا هي الانتخابات المحليه ما اقل من سنه
يعني يعني باخر 24
تجري هذه الانتخابات لكن
بالحقيقه بانه خساره اسطنبول وانقره
وادعشر مدينه كبرى لا زالت طيب اردوغان هو
تحت هذه التربيه الكبيره في هذه
الانتخابات المحليه والانتخابات المحليه
لها اهميه كبيره بقدر يعني اسطنبول الان
بمثابه انقره يعني مركز مركز من كل
النواحي السياسيه والسلطه السياسيه بركات
اسطنبول وهل اوجعت اردوغان في هذا
الانتخابات
اوجعت طبعا طبعا اوجعت اردوغان وايضا حتى
في الانتخابات الرئاسيه ايضا كان
متخلفه على
هذه المساله في في النتائج انا بتقديري
هذا من الصعب جدا وهو سيعد منذ حطه منزور
البدايه الانتخابات المحليه لاعاده هذه
الانتخابات مره اخرى لكن انا بوجهه نظري
بانه هذه المساله ليس بهذه السهوله
والتحديات الموجوده التي حطها حضرتكم
تحدثتم عنها ووظيفه تحدث عنها من الاقتصاد
الى القضاء الى حقوق الانسان الى السياسات
الخارجيه والداخليه بشكل عام وعلى راسها
القضيه الكرديه الموجوده واقصاء البرلمان
والبرلمان هنا ليست ليست له دور اطلاقا في
في نظام الرئاسي القائم الحالي وهو كل
السلطه بيد الفرد الواحد هذا الامر انا
بتقديري ما راح يعطي هذه الامكانيات لاول
مره بتاريخ تركيا المعارضه جمعت ووصلت الى
50% بالحقيقه
ومن من المعارضه هذا لا نستهين بهذه
النتيجه هذه كانت نتيجه مهمه لكن في
الحقيقه غير كافيه للنجاح
لتغيير هذه النظام الرئاسي لمتابعه المزيد
من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات